What'd you think
of that case?
Snooze fest.
[ Laughs ]
Thought it was
a snooze festival.
How many snooze fests
have you gone to now?
I haven't been for a few years
'cause parking was so tough
about four
or five years ago,
so I was like,
"[bleep] this snooze fest."
They were sleeping
in their cars.
You can't even
get into the parking lot.
People can't wait
to snooze.
[ Laughs ]
They don't --
They don't realize
they could have just
stayed at home.
Stay home and do it.
Stay home, you don't have to
come to a festival.
Oh, snoozing at home is free
if you don't turn the heat on.
Every single case
that I am a guest bailiff for,
I want to grow
and I want to learn,
and that's
what I did today.
You did?
I did.
How did you grow?
I take that back.
I learned.
I learned that that mother
is willing to give gifts.
Referring to
the woman?
The woman.
It's unclear
whether he wanted the products.
Sounds a little like a little
pushy-mom kind of scenario.
Seems like
she pushed them on him.
He might have done them
to be nice.
He's out there
chasing a dream.
He wants to act.
He wants to model.
He's got poses.
He has poses.
You saw those poses.
He was
throwing out poses.
You don't
just pose like that
unless you've
posed like that before.
Right?
That's what I saw.
He's had
at least a few gigs.
He's had a few gigs.
And then here he is --
he's got to be on set,
and he's got acne
all over his face.
If that happens to me,
I'm not
throwing those products away,
I'm lighting them
on fire
and I'm throwing them
into a gully or something.
Is that a --
yeah, gully.
Yeah, I feel like maybe there's
no gullies near where he lives,
but you never know.
Can you get Siri
on your phone
and say,
"Where's the nearest gully?"
I leave my phone in the
locker room every time I
get to the courthouse.
She'd probably just direct you
to a hockey game, I'd imagine.
[ Laughs ]